welcome everyone to this exciting
conversation on democracy race and
justice in the 21st century it's great
to see so many people here my name is
Beverly gage I'm a history professor
here at Yale and I'm also the director
of the Brady Johnson program and grant
strategy which is sponsoring this series
I want to say a few words about why
we're doing that because I think they
will maybe help to shape the
conversation here and then I will
introduce our two distinguished guests
and we will really just have a
conversation the format here is that
we're just going to talk up here for a
little bit between the three of us and
then we're going to open it up for Q&A
from the floor the reason that we are
having this kind of event which is
really as I said a moderated
conversation a conversation onstage and
a conversation with all of you is that
it gets at one of the aims of the grand
strategy program which is to combine the
knowledge that people get in the Academy
from professors being students and try
to put that knowledge in conversation in
new ways with folks who are out there in
the world being practitioners making
decisions on the ground kind of living
particularly the political challenges of
this moment day to day that's something
we try to do a little bit in the ground
strategy class and we wanted to bring
that conversation to the wider campus as
well the other two purposes behind this
new event series which is titled the big
picture so it might suggest a little bit
of what we had in mind is that we
thought in a moment like the one that
we're all living through in which the
news cycle seems to change every day if
not every hour in which many people seem
to be living in a kind of constant sense
of crisis wondering what the next thing
is that's going to happen there's a real
need for moments when you can step back
and think about the quote unquote big
picture think about where we really
stand in history over a slightly longer
time arc than just the last couple of
years but as importantly to think about
where we want
be over the long haul as a society as a
nation as a world and to have a moment
to really just project ahead around
those sorts of questions
the last purpose behind this kind of
conversation is to provide a little bit
of an opportunity to think not only
about what and where we are and where we
might want to go but also the question
of how we get there and that is a sort
of fundamental question of strategy it's
something that we talk about a lot in
the grand strategy class and the grand
strategy program but if we have a vision
for some other order some other world
some other politics what are the ways
that we can think about for making that
happen what are the ways that people in
the past have thought about doing that
and how can we start to put those pieces
together so that's really the purpose of
this series overall as I said today we
are going to be talking about the rather
large questions of democracy race and
justice in the 21st century probably
also some in the 20th century and maybe
even in the 19th and 18th century we'll
see how far how far back we go in the
conversation I am delighted to welcome
both James Forman and Vanita Gupta here
many of you know James Forman is a
distinguished law professor at Yale the
Jace Kelly Wright professor of law at
Yale and he author most recently of
locking up our own Crime and Punishment
in black America which among many other
awards and moments of praise was the
recipient of the 2018 Pulitzer Prize and
general nonfiction and if you haven't
read the book I highly recommend it not
only for what it has to say about the
history of criminal justice and mass
incarceration in the United States it's
really a book about Washington DC in
particular and the ways in which urban
politics the politics of crime beginning
in the 60s and 70s helped produce the
crisis of over policing and mass
incarceration that really took off in
the 90s and into the 2000s and so it's a
great power
see book it's a fascinating policy book
but it is also a deeply human book it is
a book about people and the good
decisions they make and the bad
decisions that they make and that
applies to just about everyone in the
book from people who end up locked up
either rightly or wrongly to many of the
politicians and policy makers many of
them black politicians and policy makers
who in response to a variety of factors
in the 60s 70s 80s and 90s got on board
with certain kinds of law and order
politics and found that it produced
consequences that were quite detrimental
so one of the things that we talked
about in the ground strategy class a
little bit is the history of unintended
consequences is the history of how you
know when you're making the right
decision and how you begin to measure
that and this is a beautiful eloquent as
well as politically insightful book in
part about that question professor
Forman is a graduate of Brown University
and of Yale Law School after graduating
from Yale Law School he clerked for
Judge William Norris of the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals and for Justice
Sandra Day O'Connor an interesting
moment in which his own political views
may or may not have aligned with the
person that he was working for he joined
the public defender service and worked
there for many years in Washington DC
helped to found a charter school in
Washington that now operates in juvenile
prisons in juvenile jails in DC for
students who have been incarcerated and
had dropped out of high school he taught
at Georgetown Law School from 2003 to
2011 and since 2011 he has been back
here at Yale teaching a variety of
courses from constitutional law criminal
justice law to a course in which Yale
law students and the occasional
undergraduate as well actually work with
and learn with and teach with students
in Connecticut prison I also want to
welcome Vanita Gupta in this case back
to Yale I did not know when I invited
her to participate in this conversation
that she is
a 1996 graduate of Yale is in fact a
history major am i right history major
yeah so I'm always very excited as a
history professor when like history
major is take what they learn and then
they go out and they changed the world
and do all of these transformative
things at the moment she is the
president and CEO of the Leadership
Conference on civil and human rights
which has an interesting history of its
own was an organization founded in 1950
really by some of the towering figures
of the labor and civil rights movement
most notably a philip Randolph the
creator of the the founder of the
Brotherhood of sleeping car porters in
the 1920s who went on to also be one of
the great visionaries and architects
behind the modern civil rights movement
the purpose of the organization today is
in part to take a lot of different
progressive organizations with a lot of
different agendas everyone from the ACLU
to the n-double-a-cp to organizations
working around gay rights working around
immigrant rights and try to see and
correct me if I'm getting any of this
wrong if everyone can get together on
the same page and speak at least
sometimes with a single voice she too
has a long history working in the area
of civil rights and human rights she's a
graduate not only of Yale but of NYU Law
School she went on from law school to
work as the deputy legal director and
director of the center for justice at
the ACLU as well as previously to that
the n-double-a-cp legal defense and
education fund she has been involved in
some of the most dramatic civil rights
cases of our time beginning with the
overturning of the wrongful convictions
of 38 people in Tulia Texas one of her
first big cases and perhaps most notably
for us from 2014 to 2017 she was head of
the Civil Rights Division in the
Department of Justice in the final years
of the Obama administration and worked
widely in areas ranging from policing
and criminal justice to reform to
disability rights hate crimes to voting
rights and hopefully we'll have a chance
to touch on all of these today I want to
mention a few
a few things that she did at the DOJ
that you might want to talk about him
that hopefully we'll have a chance to
talk about as head of the Civil Rights
Division she helped to investigate the
Ferguson and the Chicago Police
Department's she led challenges to the
Texas and North Carolina voter ID laws
and to many of the transgender laws
particularly in North Carolina that came
up in the last couple of years so please
join me in welcoming these two
extraordinary people James Forman and
Vanita Gupta up to the stage and we'll
begin our conversation
[Applause]
all right well I set up there that part
of our purpose here does this sound okay
is to do a little bit of big-picture
thinking around these very big words
that we've taken as our mission for this
afternoon so I thought maybe I would
start out just with a question to you
Vinita which is the so I'm a historian
you were a history major and maybe you
could tell us a little bit about the
ways in which your organization had a
vision in 1950 what it's doing today but
particularly I think we're at a moment
in time where many people who care about
these words democracy race justice think
we're living in pretty bleak times think
we might be living in times in which we
are somehow going back to a less
enlightened pass in which challenges
that we thought from the past had been
laid to rest are now coming up again so
I wonder if you might just think in a
little bit of historical perspective
about where we stand in history and
where your where your organization is
right now sure and it's great to be here
I was just talking about really that I
haven't been back in Harkness since in
20 years and I'm getting flashbacks of
all the classes I took but I did find my
way here and there wasn't a grand
strategy program at the time that I was
an undergraduate and I'm a huge fan of
Jameses and always look forward to being
in conversation with him so really glad
to be here today
so the Leadership Conference as you said
was founded in 1950 and it was really
forged by Jewish labor and
african-american leaders who at the time
in 1950 there had been a long campaign
and would still be a long campaign to
fight for the Voting Rights Act but it
was forged out of this notion that the
fight for civil rights couldn't be won
by one group alone but would need to be
waged in coalition and really I think
part of that was out of the recognition
that folks particularly
african-americans and the South were
literally dying for the right to vote
and the power that needed to be
assembled to move
a very entrenched racist Congress to get
to a place to enact the Voting Rights
Act would need to be power assembled
across communities on across
organizations deploying the power of the
labor movement of the Faith Movement and
of the civil rights movement and you
know in a lot of ways I will say you
know when I was leaving the Justice
Department kind of with a pretty keen
eye about what was going to happen given
how the president had campaigned and in
with the nomination of Jeff Sessions
really needing to be at a place well
there was a part of me that wanted to
hide under a sofa for four years and I
realized that that would be I think
really largely and I say this despair is
kind of the right of the privilege that
we needed to go out and really fight for
vulnerable communities given what was at
stake and I wanted to be somewhere where
we could make sure that in this time
where it felt pretty clear that all of
our communities were going to be
attacked that the progress significant
that had been made in the last several
decades around issues of racial justice
and inclusion while highly imperfect
that there was a place that would be
able to make us more than the sum of our
parts that we could that we could be
kind of a place at the Leadership
Conference to be a force multiplier
across our groups and communities
because we knew that in this moment
which I do believe has been a crisis
moment and we are living still in a
crisis moment we would need to really
marshal all of our voices to fight for
voting rights to protect LGBTQ
communities to protect dreamers and
immigrants given how viscerally
anti-immigrant the the administration
has been and I will say that as you know
we'll have more of a conversation about
this but I realized that in this moment
when I joined the Leadership Conference
I had worked with the Leadership
Conference when I had been at the Lu and
LDF and the goal is to be able to come
together on strategy and kind of deploy
all of the some groups of ground game
like move on and
the ECL you some groups have litigation
power some groups are about ton of
congressional power some groups are
really in the states helping to build
power in public well for the kinds of
things we want but if we could come
together and we knew that Washington
would be a largely defensive resistance
posture we needed to be a strategic hub
for the resistance while also figuring
out how do we keep momentum going at the
state local level around issues where
there had been really kind of important
change we didn't want the federal
government to slow that down in areas of
criminal justice reform and acting
automatic voter registration and things
that were actually moving in the states
but look just to close out on this
question I think that one of the things
that we had to do was we couldn't be
everything to all people in this moment
as a coalition that we weren't going to
win by kind of being diffused and
issuing 20 press releases after 20
attacks on our communities represented
by the Leadership Conference and we
really did some quick thinking in real
time in 2017 about what it would mean
what we needed to focus on and at that
time and still to this day we have
really centered our work on fighting for
some of our democratic institutions and
democratic norms and it feels abstract
and wonky but actually without the
courts and a fair and independent
judiciary without the census which I say
is the least sexy least sexy civil
rights issue and yet is one of the most
important for structural democracy
without voting rights everything else
that we care about from criminal justice
reform educational equity fighting for
economic security and healthcare we have
no place to go when these institutions
are under so much attack and so that has
been some of our focus and to me there
is a cycling in and out of history
through through our history where groups
have really had to Center the fight
around democracy even as we have tried
to protect the most vulnerable
communities amongst us maybe I could put
a similar question to you so this
question are we are we in the moment of
crisis that is certainly one of our
dominant public narratives sort of see
in a broader historical trajectory maybe
in the trajectory that you cover in your
book the last 40 or 50 years maybe
thinking back to a little of your own
family's history a family with a deep
history in the civil rights movement of
the 60s and 70s and particularly I guess
in the area that you really think about
and study which is criminal justice and
in a moment like this it seems like we
have some competing narratives about
where we stand
in criminal justice we're at a moment of
promise a moment of crisis sure that um
and thank you for inviting me and it's
so great when I saw that that Vinita was
gonna be coming I was so excited to join
this conversation she's somebody that
I've watched her work in the in the
government and over the last couple of
years and she's such an amazing figure
y'all are lucky too we're lucky to have
her here on campus so I'm really excited
I mean I think in the area that I work
in you know in the criminal legal system
I don't think there's any question but
that we are in a much worse position as
a country and in particular so for all
of us but in particular for poor
communities in particular for black and
brown communities it's I'm normally have
the story of progress because for the
most part I think it is true that on
matters of racial justice as flawed as
we are as a country it is largely a
story of progress however in this area
we are is one of the areas where things
are worse than they were before brown
things are worse than they were before
the Civil Rights Act and the Voting
Rights Act and I don't say that lightly
because like I said in most in most ways
I think that is not true but in this
area it is true
we you know if you're if you're a black
man who is born in my generation you are
four to five times more likely to go to
prison in your lifetime than a black man
born in my father's generation and we
don't have that same data for
african-american women but all of the
all the data we have suggests similar
that similarly would be true and so I
think that when you say that there are
competing narratives I think it's true
that in the last couple of years um
we've started to see in part because of
the work that Bonita has helped to lead
but we've started to see a bit of a
relief and a bit of progress I think in
to my mind maybe the single most
significant thing that has happened in
my area is the reinforcement of 1.4
million people in the state of Florida
with felony convictions the largest
Rhian franchise 'men that we've had
since the Voting Rights Act and that
puts together that pulls together two of
the areas that Deveny has been talking
about was democracy and the criminal
legal system but but the but we've had a
20-year crime decline and in that
20-year crime decline we've only had a
very small decline in the size of our
prison system I mean so we're continuing
to have people cycle through our prison
system despite the fact that the country
has gotten so much safer and so you
would think that some of the politics um
of crime would have changed and so what
I fear what I fear about for my issue at
this moment is that for the period of
time I was writing about in my book for
basically the 70s 80s and 90s the
project of building more prisons and
getting harsher and more pure
was an affirmative political project the
you know William bar right authored a
paper the case for more incarceration
when he was the Attorney General so this
wasn't this was conscious that isn't the
case anymore for the most part there
isn't the same political project people
aren't running in the same way on that
kind of project but what's happened
instead is that it's become entrenched
and it's become taken for granted so
it's just become part of how it is that
we have so many people locked up so I
fear that the criminal legal system is
becoming like segregation segregation
was something that people fought for
then they stopped fighting for it but
it's still but now we just take it for
granted our neighborhoods are segregated
our schools are de facto segregated and
we just live with it and I worry that
the same thing is how it has happened in
this issue well I want to get to some of
these policy questions but there's
there's a word that's come up already
which is this idea of progress and
whether historical progress is a useful
way of framing the history of the United
States and the last say since 1950 since
the founding of the Leadership
Conference since the era when your book
begins or if we need to think about
other stories I think Americans are very
attached to the idea of progress I think
liberals and progressives in particular
are very attached to that as the kind of
grand narrative of the American past and
yet it seems to me that that sort of
sets people up to be shocked when
something like the election of Donald
Trump comes along when things start
happening that don't fit into a kind of
progress narrative it's hard to wrap
your mind around where that comes from
it's hard to think about an analytic
framework that's going to substitute for
this idea of progress so I'm just
wondering in your in your
in your own writing in your own work
sort of how you wrestle with the idea of
whether whether progress is a useful
framework how we measure whether we're
making progress and particularly at a
moment where as I said many people would
say we're at an end of progress or we're
at some some some some moving backward
no I don't know that history has a
direction but I just wonder how you
think about that issue
and experience it in your own your own
work yeah I mean I don't so progress
there's nothing at all linear about
progress and progress can mean so many
things I think right now I mean there
was a lot of time in my first two years
when people just felt the sense of
despair and kind of bleak Ness and they
felt like anything that they had done
was worth nothing because look at where
the country was look at who voted for
this president and the like and I I do
actually think that it is important for
us to not ignore that this country was
born out of slavery it was we lived with
systemic Jim Crow laws it doesn't we are
a deeply segregated in fact a resected
country today but but I don't want to
kind of I have a look at maybe it's like
that I don't want to dishonor or kind of
what people went through before in this
but I agree with James about the fact
that on issues like mass incarceration
we are much worse off today than we were
before Brown and that the legitimizing
and and their kind of normalization of a
criminal legal system that we have had
for forty five fifty years in this
country is is a really disturbing thing
because it doesn't fit the narrative of
progress it doesn't fit the narrative of
us kind of moving in one direction I
mean some people are like okay you move
take two steps forward you take one step
back we've got a history in this country
where we've had signs of making progress
followed by deep retrenchment and
backlash and so I don't I don't think
that we're kind of
we may have a North Star I'm a civil
rights lawyer so I am a deeply
optimistic person you cannot do this
work unless you have a sense of optimism
that you are driving towards change and
that the only thing in this country that
has ever made a difference is people
believing in in the possibility of
change and I think this country has seen
a lot of change on a lot of issues but
we can't be naive or Pollyannish about
you know where we are today and and in a
lot of ways look at the forces that were
marching out in broad daylight with
torches lighting up their faces and
Charlotte's well those forces have
always been around in this country and
what we're seeing now is it you know
kind of much more visible coming out of
the darkness around these forces such
that there are people in the white house
who who occupy and take and have hold
white supremacist views and are
advancing a white supremacist agenda in
a way that frankly gives we've been
screaming about this and the areas of
voter suppression and you know people
are all like oh you guys are conspiracy
theorists and I mean I was telling James
I testified last week before Congress on
HR 1 which is this massive democracy
reform legislation it's on everything
from money and politics to restoring the
Voting Rights Act I mean you name it
it's it's like a very aspirational bill
and the next day Mitch McConnell says
well this bill is just about the
Democratic Party trying to grab power
they're trying to have an election a
federal holiday for for voting and I was
like you just basically laid bare that
your whole premise for the for your
party is to prevent people that it is
well I should say that that they survive
and exist by suppressing the vote they
do not want people to vote and it's a we
have to recognize that as much as things
change they also have you know there's a
way in which the kind of the the moving
away from having it be over and out of
the open to then having been filled with
proxies in terms that seem like an
oculus and neutral to now I think we're
being a little bit portal back to a play
where we can say guys this is what we
have been talking about for so long and
y'all never you thought we had made the
straight line from from Jim Crow to to
where we are today when actually the
very forces that have long been
existence to suppress the vote for
african-americans Latinos and others we
are now seeing through the kind of in
the last two years all of this kind of
become much more visible to you to the
American public in a way that frankly I
think is important and helpful and in a
way that progressives have largely taken
for granted I just wanted to pick up on
something that Vinita said about being a
civil rights attorney and being
optimistic in in in part in response to
a question about progress and and and I
agree with that I mean I think I
basically think there are two ways that
you keep going in this work and one of
them is what Vanita said one of them is
on the optimism and but there is another
one as well and I think that that I want
to raise up i when I was in law school
here it was long enough ago that there
was a guy in LA a motorist a driver who
was beaten to within an inch of his life
by the Los Angeles Police Department and
it was caught on video
his name was Rodney King and it's hard
for students today to understand but
this was the first time any of this that
sisters ever caught on video the first
time well knew what happened talked
about it stories but had never been
caught on video and at the time at this
law school I and other members of the
black Law Students Association and
basically everybody in this country
who's talking about this issue said well
of course those police officers are
going to be convicted but the problem is
what happens when it's not on video and
then of course they were acquitted and
we were stunned and la goes up in flames
and I am devastated and thinking about
dropping out of Law School
because I had gone to law school to try
to may make progress for my people and
now at this moment where the and I'm
learning the rules so that I can use the
rules on behalf of poor people and
oppressed people and people of color and
now at the moment when you actually need
the rules it's shown to be a total sham
and I was completely demoralized and I
went to talk to my dad my dad was in the
civil rights movement
Beverly made reference to it my both my
parents were they were in snick the
Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee and my dad had been beaten by
the LA Police Department in the 1950s
and he wrote about it in his book and so
now we're in the 90s and the same thing
is happening and there's still no
recourse in law and so I go I'm talking
to my dad and I'm like dad it's all a
sham 40 years later nothing has changed
and my dad's normal move in those
moments was to tell me the progress
story but this time he said something
different and he made a point to me
which I've always taken with me because
I sit it alongside the progress the
optimism story when I need to keep going
which is he said look when we were
fighting when we were marching when we
were being beaten in the movement we
weren't doing it for tomorrow we weren't
doing it for our lifetimes
we knew that in a country that has had
slavery and Jim Crow for as long as this
one has had which is to say 85% of our
country's history right 1619 to 1954 or
1619 to 1965 pick your year we knew
that we work in a defeating now we were
fighting for tomorrow and he said we
were fighting for 10,000 years from
tomorrow and the point that my dad was
making that I've always taken with me is
you fight sometimes you draw inspiration
from the belief that you are part of a
narrative part of progress and sometimes
you draw inspiration from the fact that
fighting injustice is how you remain
human and so for me I always put when I
think about progress I think of progress
and their optimism and then I also think
of humanity
I feel like fighting injustice even if
you aren't going to win or don't know if
you'll win or don't know if you'll win
in your lifetime is about holding on to
your to to your humanity I I had felt
this so many times over the last two
years and I have felt a and so many
times in the last two years kind of a
deep insufficiency as a leader when you
just felt like you could show up on the
street with like ten thousand people and
I've been a part of a lot of marches in
last two years where we did that because
you just you feel like you have to show
up for Humanity I mean the family
separation issue was kind of the most
visceral one of my lowest points in last
year's in their Benefiel but this thing
about that there for me I mean this is a
different version of it and other
predecessors of ours have said this but
that there is hope in the struggle even
when you know you're gonna lose because
the sheer process of organizing and
trying to show up for other human beings
who are being tortured or having their
children grabbed out of their arms at
the southern border with Congress that
has completely been asleep at the switch
with state lawmakers that are supporting
this agenda with you know in in those
moments where it wasn't that we showed
up 30,000 strong in Washington DC at the
end of June because we thought this was
going to end
family separation at the border it was
almost there it's like we had nothing
left to show to display our power in
that moment and we had to do the thing
that we knew what to do which was to
organize and like take to the streets
and that feeling I mean you got to
understand I came from having subpoena
power at the Justice Department I mean I
was like you know showing up at police
department to feeling the sense of like
deep powerlessness in the face of
incredible inhumanity and outrage and so
this thing of what you're saying is so
deeply resonant to me today in a way
that it never was even before even when
I was at you know outside of government
it's a real thing and to me the day we
stopped doing that because we will lose
repeatedly and both you and I know of
the legions of people who fought and
lost repeatedly but that's the hope
piece that then gets tacked on which is
we aren't just fighting to win yes we're
fighting to win but a lot of what we're
fighting for is to keep that struggle
alive because the day that that the day
that we start to become complacent about
that or the day that we say you know
what we can't win let's throw our hands
up and do something else to me is a very
destructive place for us to be but it's
not to say that it isn't hurt
emotionally to live in that space but
that is I think some of the lessons and
I feel like you know the last few years
you are seeing millions of people who
never before thought of themselves as
activists who felt the need they they
woke up and said what wait this isn't
what I thought this country was even
though a lot of folks of color knew that
this country was exactly this but they
said you know we need a we need in some
way figure out how we are engaging to
try to struggle to make a difference
even though we will lose a thousand
times and you know to me even that gives
me hope I wonder if we can build on that
and maybe move a little from the from
the heart to the head and it seems you
know no matter really
what your politics are or where you're
coming in on these issues one of the
challenges of this moment is that
there's so much happening right there's
so much happening all the time that we
see a real dispersal of energy I think
you talked a little bit about despair as
one as one possible outcome but there is
a kind of impulse to action for a lot of
different people in a lot of different
ways and then a real confusion about
what kind of action is actually going to
be the most useful form of action is it
going to be going to law school learning
to work within the court and justice
system dealing with litigation is it
going to be showing up to a protest is
it going to be working for particular
candidates so I wonder if you can talk a
little bit about how you see I guess I
would call it the strategic landscape
maybe or at least the political
landscape but both sort of where you
think the points of intersection and
useful energy are at the moment and also
I guess a little of how you have made
those decisions in your own life when
you're being pulled in in both of your
cases in so many different directions
and you're addressing things that seem
really so so large all right so I've
thought this is a really important
question and I've thought a lot about it
I spent a fair amount of college and
probably most of law school and I
suspect
Vanita will be able to say the same were
debating among my friends and in my own
head really two things like what was
going to be the issue that I was going
to take up right because especially in
law school like you graduate law school
and you you're gonna start a job and
it's gonna be in an area you know what I
mean like you may be interested in a lot
of things but like you're going to
become an environmental lawyer or a
voting
it's like even within the public
interest realm or a public defender like
you have to pick a topic it's a
challenge for everyone in this room I
know I know and so that's why I'm trying
to share how much I rest so one was that
I mean I remember I was in law school
with Van Jones and I remember van
running around then talking about green
jobs and like environmental racism in
that in their early 90s and he was like
that's the thing that we need to be work
rights working on and he and everybody
was trying to figure this out for
themselves and then there's the question
of like methodology right okay so now
you've got your area but are you doing
direct service work are you are you
filing lawsuits are you doing impact
litigation are you going into government
are you doing direct you know organizing
and man I came up with like why remember
we came up with a different like we
would come I came up with names of like
organizations like education action
litigation for struggle we're like at
our nonprofits they're like terrible
names but we were trying to capture all
the the modes of action in addition to
the topic so here's I guess where I am
now here's where I got at the end of law
school and I've remained there my
thinking has remained pretty firm since
then there isn't a most impactful there
isn't a most important topic and there
isn't a most impactful methodology you
need to be you needed like which doesn't
mean you can skip over the top of like
rest you skip over the skip a step of
wrestling through all of this for
yourself you have to but in fact there
isn't a most important area and there
isn't a most impactful methodology what
there is going to be is the one that's
right for you and that's
it's truly not a cop-out what I mean by
that is there's going to be an issue
that is going to grab you you're not
going to be able to go to sleep like you
are going to be thinking about this
thing all of the time it's going to be
the thing where you feel like you aren't
going to be fully human if you're not
working on it and there's going to be a
methodology that's going to connect to
your particular skillset and abilities
and interests like this is where I think
the head and the heart really are
connected to go back to because because
at the heart level you some people want
to be sitting in like in in the jail
four hours a day talking to people and
then going and driving out into
neighborhoods and talking to families
about their struggles and pulling those
facts together to bring it back to like
a pleading that you're gonna like knock
out in 30 minutes because that's all you
have other people want to kind of read
read reports and cases and reflect on
them and file lawsuits other people want
to like want to to tell hobby any and
you got to figure out which person you
are and then you put those two together
the issue that you can't stop thinking
about and the kind of person you are and
that then for you is your work and you
just got to know you're gonna let some
things go there's gonna be some topics
that you're not gonna be able to work on
and there's gonna be some methodologies
you're not gonna be able to pursue then
might have been right maybe I should
have done environmental right you really
mean like it's not any less important
than criminal justice reform
but there was one that spoke to me in a
particular way and for me there was a
way that I wanted to fight it which was
as a public defender in the trenches in
courts and that was right for me kind of
at that moment and then later on I
thought about it right in a different
way in a more kind of academic way
yeah and I'm I I'm trying to find points
of disagreement but I don't I don't have
them I I mean I think that that's just I
think that's real I mean I think the
piece that you ended with is important
which is you may go in and out of a lot
of issues in sectors I mean it's one of
the beauties and privileges of this
education that you're getting here and
where you may end up going is I mean I
have worked on a lot of different issues
as a public interest lawyer I am NOT
litigating now I think you can kind of
become very attached to the tactic that
you are working on and I will say the
funding industrial complex makes it such
that you're supposed to kind of elevate
your one tactic or your two issues as
being like the end-all be-all that
solved the poverty crisis but when in
reality there really isn't I mean you
look at criminal justice and the folks
that are working to transform the system
there are people running to be district
attorneys right more recently which is
not something that I ever grew up
thinking was a path of resistance to
their folks that as you said are working
in the state legislatures or folks that
are litigating you know and there are a
lot of for a lot of folks are working on
those issues I'm using that tactic and
thinking this is the one that is going
to transform the whole thing and the
reality is it takes it takes all of it
these problems are serious deep and
entrenched they're not going to get
solved overnight
and but the you know going in and out
and using a variety of tactics I think I
mean there's some people who just like
there they are doing it for 35 years and
good you know gah blossom they're kind
of doing the same thing and they've been
righteous believers I've I never thought
I would be in government I've spent my
whole life suing the government and yet
like when I had this man told just weeks
after Michael Brown was killed in
Ferguson to oversee the Ferguson Police
Department I mean I kind of it was very
odd for a little while to be inside
government in having a different set of
responsibilities around these issues
than I did when I was at the ACLU but
both the inside and the outside tactics
or books like strategy I should say
we're really important to to
being able to make a dent in a problem
of over-policing and and force and and
the myriad of problems that we face as a
country so I you know I think that you
want to look for places that fit the
place you are in your life and be open
and flexible to moving on when you feel
like okay well I want to become an
organizer now because I did this I
litigated for the first ten years
representing people who had been
wrongfully convicted or convicted in the
criminal legal system and particularly
in the drug war and at a certain point
you know we had some great successes and
victories but every victory that I had
as a litigator just felt like this like
drop in the bucket against this tsunami
of you know in the Texas case that you
refer to Beverly I mean yes we won these
great high-profile exonerations but at
the time Texas was spending far more
money on building prisons and on higher
education and I didn't yeah the
exonerations were a useful story to try
to push reform but I ended up really
wanting and focus on changing laws and
that tinker I felt I mean people need
representation but I had decided at that
ten years on that I wanted to to kind of
do organizing on policy work and so but
I do believe that it is important both
to feel like you are doing work that you
find is actually meaningfully about
creating change and you want to be
strategic I yeah there and that means a
lot of different things to different
people but but I think you want to think
about how how do you fit within the
broader in the broader kind of movement
for justice if you decide you're gonna
do justice work what is your purpose and
understand with some humility that you
are approaching it from a particular
vantage point and others are trying to
change it you know from they may left
flank you they may be more kind of
middle-of-the-road
but what is the how do you work with
with folks and what is your strategy
ultimately to kind of push even the
limits of your own tactic to achieve
change and don't be satisfied with the
four corners of whatever
take an approach you take okay so can I
just sit just one more thing because I
said I I want just to say I do think
there's one way in which like you have
to like there's a I was saying there's
all these different choices right and
you have to find the one that's right
for you but there is I think one way
where there's actually kind of right and
wrong choice or way of thinking about it
and and I just I do want to just finish
with that which is that I think it's
crucial remember my I I remember my mom
talking mom so my parents both parents
were in this all rights movement so my
dad's black my mom's white and I
remember my mom talking to me about
people who had who's stayed in the
movement over the course of their
lifetime in the civil rights movement
versus people that were there for like a
short period of time like they went to
Mississippi Freedom Summer or they were
in snick for a year and then they kind
of went and then they basically moved
and that just stopped being a part of
their life and what my mom said was that
in her opinion that it was crucial in
the work that you had to be doing the
work for yourself not for somebody else
and she said now when I say that that's
gonna sound like it sounds like wait
like cuz we're all you know Public
Interest public spirit like we're
working you know we're like we're not
selfish like the selfish people are the
people that go and take have like follow
a less virtuous paths
than we do but the point that she was
making was that if you're doing the work
if you're doing social justice work for
somebody else like for the people who
are supposed to be the beneficiaries of
your action then you're gonna of you're
gonna get burnt out and you're gonna get
it burn out pretty quickly and you're
gonna get disillusioned because you're
gonna start to develop a mentality which
is that like the people that you're
working for are supposed to be grateful
for you they're not supposed to
challenge you they're supposed to be
lifting you up after all you're doing
this work for that and her point was
what she was saying was that she was
like
I as a white woman doing this I was
doing it because I did not think that I
could live in a society of this form of
segregation and oppression and not be
fighting like I was fighting for myself
and for my own liberation and that she
was saying she believed put her in a
position that she could be challenged
she could be critiqued she could have
people say well I don't let you know I
don't like what you're doing I don't
want you to be part of this movement at
this moment in this particular time and
she was much more open to that she than
the people that went into it with this
mentality that they were they were
helping somebody else so that's the one
thing I just want that for me I just
want to end on because I do think there
there is a right way and a wrong way to
enter the work well I have lots more
questions that I could ask but we do
want to take a chance to open up the
floor to questions there are microphones
going around and these can be questions
about particular policies particularly
in UA shion's of the conversation we're
already having I should note that this
is being recorded so if you ask a
question you will be on record in some
morphus way out in the ether as having
asked this question made this query but
you can just raise your hands and
microphone will come around while you're
contemplating and while hands are going
up I do want to ask a more particular
question which is about an area that we
have already discussed a little bit but
it is about from where we stand in
criminal justice and criminal justice
reform at the moment and we talked a
little bit about competing narratives of
our moment but I think there is at least
one story out that there were at a real
moment of possibility and of change and
that it seems to be one of the few areas
where there's kind of some level of
cooperative bipartisan work going on and
that also much of the work that is going
on in this area is happening not at the
federal level where there's not oh well
there's a lot happening but not a lot
along those lines although there's been
some interesting recent legislation that
you might want to talk about but that
this is something that people are doing
at the local level at the city level at
the state level so I just wonder what
your read is on where we stand
around those issues if you could picture
out 30 to 40 years to if it took say 40
years for a system of mass incarceration
to build can we envision a world in 40
years that looks radically different
than that are we actually on a path to
seeing that and just kind of where where
we stand with all of this I told you I
was being strategic mmm nice I think
that it is a moment of possibility
especially as you were saying Beverly at
the at the at the state and local level
so 88% of people in prison in this
country are in state county or local
prisons or jails and 85 percent of law
enforcement in this country is state
county or local so there's always a
disproportionate amount of media
attention placed on what happens in the
federal government just because like you
know the big papers are gonna have
multiple reporters in DC and they don't
have multiple reporters you know in
every state Capitol they don't have any
in most state capitals so what happens
there gets gets largely overlooked but
but what's happening there is where the
action is and although the progress what
what I'll say about the state county and
local level is that the progress is slow
right that is to say the you know the
incarceration rate which peaked in
around 2008 2009 2010 has only draw it
is dropped consistently but only
slightly since then so if you look at
the line it's sort of going up like this
and then it Peaks here and then it's
sort of you know going like this so at
the rate of decline that we currently
have
I think it'll you know be another
50 years or something the Sentencing
Project has estimated before we would
ever get down to where we started and
crime meanwhile is is down to where we
started so you might be just say well
we'd be justified in having these kind
of incarceration rates given our crime
rates so that so we're gonna so it's
gonna have to be more aggressive
significantly and the other challenge is
that the factors that lead to having the
largest prison system in the world
aren't the same factors that sustain it
by which I mean now that the system has
been built there are a tremendous amount
of structural vested interest in
maintaining the system interest which
didn't which I don't think are
principally responsible for its creation
but now they're there now there's jobs
and now they're the people responded
right unions and and capitalism
responded and people saw okay now we
have this industry and so now there's a
whole bunch of folks there that are
fighting even if they're not again
engaged in mass incarceration as a
political project they're just engaged
in mass incarceration as a I need to
keep my job or my business needs to
continue to make money project and so
that is that has made the attempts to
push back it's made it more challenging
but I do think what I'll say is that
though the progress has been slow it is
in one direction that is to say if you
look at something like felon in giving
people who are returning citizens and
formerly incarcerated folks the right to
vote all of the momentum all of the
direction is in favor of Rhian
franchising we don't have you know it's
not like we have ten you know five bills
pushing for a reinforcement and another
five pushing for disenfranchise its in
its ten its eight eight to zero or ten
to zero now it needs to be forty to zero
right that's the problem of it not being
enough but it is all going in that
direction so in my mind it's an area
that is very very ripe for energy and
activism and reform and the one
community that I'll say that I think
needs to be where there is a strategic
opportunity in this moment is working
class and poor white communities who are
outside of cities who are in rural areas
who are in distant suburban areas these
are legislators and I see it in
Connecticut all the time
these are legislators that right now if
you talk go to talk to them about the
mass incarceration problem they're like
oh that I'll just pick Connecticut
that's a New Haven Bridgeport and
Hartford problem they don't think it's
their problem and they're not voting for
a reform legislation and they're who we
need to win but guess what it is their
problem I teach in Connecticut prison
there's a lot of poor and working-class
class white folks in prison in this
country and right now in part because
the advocacy has had this racial
dimension and appropriately so because
of the disproportional disproportionate
racial consequences but in part because
of the advocacy this is a group of
people that's been allowed to kind of
pretend like it's not there their
constituents and the other thing here's
the thing that makes it very hard for
some of those constituents to develop a
voice they've committed a crime or
they're the family member of somebody
who's committed a crime right there feel
a certain amount of shame and stigma
about that now that was true of
everybody who was in the criminal
justice system thirty years ago but
thirty years ago before the analysis of
racial injustice and the analysis of the
new Jim Crow black and brown prisoners
and their families as well we're feeling
that stigma in that Shane was like well
I'm not going to go down to the
Statehouse to talk about my problem
because I'm a criminal
but now for communities of color there's
like a new there's a way to talk about
it as a racial justice issue
but for poor white communities they
still don't have that so they still have
the shame in the stigma without the
racial injustice analysis and their
remaining quiet so I think a real
strategic moment would be to think about
how to organize in those communities so
that folks begin to lift up their voices
because they're getting hammered by the
system not quite as hard but hammered
nonetheless but I think that the opioid
crisis and the ways in which rural white
America I mean it's a different paradigm
around the opioid crisis than what was
used around the crack cocaine you know
epidemic crisis in the 80s and everyone
I mean I think there is a even for some
of the most conservative lawmakers is a
fairly clear understanding that the way
they may not they may deracinated that
there is a different kind of more
compassionate public health oriented
response to the opioid crisis which is
largely you know affecting white rural
America in parts of the country and I
mean I I agree with you I think that
there's to me you I'm both a deeply
idealistic person but very pragmatic and
when when to me it was actually a
struggle for civil rights advocates to
feel comfortable in 2009 intense
entering race in this fight because when
we were in state legislatures
particularly in some of the red states
that were actually pioneering some of
the reform in places like Texas and some
other places it was really largely
driven out of the fiscal crisis because
need actually have to balance their
budgets in a way that the federal
government doesn't and I had real
struggle I remember sitting down and
talking to Michelle Alexander who you
know at that time I was writing her book
and I I was just like I can't go into
the state legislatures and start
screaming about the new Jim Crow much as
I believed it to be exactly what is
happening in this country to convince
some of these folks to put two pass laws
and I want to bring these people on
so that we can change the law they're
coming at it for a different reason than
I am or that we are but should we not
like build these weird alliances to get
it done and the or concern always was
and it was complete still is very
legitimate that these are like reforms
that tinker at the edges are not
changing the paradigm but ultimately as
somebody who's trying to get laws passed
or trying to get them changed these
dynamics I think are really important
what you're talking about in Connecticut
I think is about like how do you
actually both like build you know I
don't believe that you have to have a
shared narrative and analysis to be
working on a campaign together and
exactly you know I think sometimes
you're gonna have folks that are in it
for a very different reason a reason
that you may not think is particularly
important but that we're you know human
beings are are at stake and your issue
is at stake and kind of the decency of
humanity is at stake and you build those
alliances kind of being very clear-eyed
about the limitations of that kind of
partnership and coalition building and
so I think it's hard when you're doing
this work around criminal justice reform
I mean look I agree I think there's
tremendous back in 2003 when I was
working on these Texas cases when you
were a public defender I don't think it
just felt like there was like one
trajectory like there was no it it was
just so hard to see any change because
every election cycle these sentences
would get ratcheted up and we were
criminalizing more and more stuff from
school discipline to immigration to you
know substance use disorder to mental
health and it was just one traductor ii
and it was like this way and it was you
know and and so now you know we are
seeing tremendous progress but we have
been challenged and James you've talked
about this that we are gonna have to
change how we understand crimes of
violence and what we do to people who
are tagged violent offenders and that is
a even a lot of folks that are kind of
in the reform space and movement
are not ready to do that but there is no
way to get back to the 1970 weights and
without kind of confronting the the kind
of really dramatic like elongation of
sentences that are keeping people behind
bars for the rest of their lives without
confronting some things that have become
so normalized for us in this country and
deeply uncomfortable to change and so uh
you know I think one of the things that
has happened has been some recognition
of the importance of depoliticizing
criminal justice policy making and
having it be you know evidence-based or
more evidence-based whatever that means
but we have a lot of work to do to
actually you know confront some of the
some of the laws that will need to be
undone and some of the responses that
we've had as a country to some things
that make us feel you know we all want
to live in safe communities and that are
going to have to force us to confront
what our solutions and how how can we
deal with some of these issues with a
very different response than a purely
criminal a purely criminal one criminal
legal questions out there yeah
hi first of all thank you for coming and
thank you for everything you've said so
far especially what you've said about
trying to find your path in the larger
field of public service work that's
definitely what's on my mind and a lot
of people's minds right now so I
appreciate that
but my question gets out what you've
already talked about a little bit sort
of about the emotive context of your
work both personally and professionally
the first thing is I thought when you
guys were talking about your motivations
or how you keep going and a really
oftentimes difficult line of work is I
expected one of you or to comment on
sort of the feeling of indignation or
anger because that's something that I
definitely have felt a lot on campus and
in my personal life and myself and I was
wondering if you feel that also and if
you feel that's a productive tool in the
toolbox or whether that's something you
have to overcome to do your work
effectively especially if you're
building coalitions or trying to
convince people that don't see the same
way as you because that's something I
struggle with and I'd love to hear a
perspective on that and then secondly
how do you deal with apathy and others
for your issue for the line of work you
do I know that especially at Yale and in
my own friend group in my classes it's
hard to sometimes convince people who
feel like they have no stake in this
fight to do something to get involved
and for me personally that's difficult
to engage with and I'm assuming that
professionally you find that even more
difficult and so I'm wondering how those
two emotions play into your work I feel
angry a lot why would we why would I get
up in the morning honestly if I didn't
feel some level of anger about the state
of the world and go beyond our own cuz
I'm like hope and change and but but
it's true like I I think it's of a piece
I think there are ways to be debilitated
by anger and to have anger basically
push one to despair in
and then become an excuse for not doing
anything and that's where the apathy
piece of where you come out really
frustrates me I I mean I'm gonna be
honest with you I find it hard the
hardest I would rather be talking to
somebody who is so righteous in their
belief against immigrants one against
black folks and against folks of color
then to be with somebody who is just
apathetic because I don't understand I
just don't understand apathy like I
don't know how what is in the person's
brain chemically it allows them to like
just kind of you know I'm like maybe I
want some of that but I don't how can
you not be angry right and so and you
know I feel like the day I stopped being
angry I feel like that that's the day I
stop being human about but I think it's
what you do with the anger and and I
mean James said this there's a lot of
different ways to deal with that feeling
I know people choose different ways to
deal with it for some folks it really is
about like organizing from the outside
and you know it's there's there's
different for others it's it's about
being in court and you know filing the
the pleading that's gonna try to stop
this policy or whatever but I I think
they're both anger is a can be a very
healthy emotion to act to action but the
question is what do you do with it and I
think after the 2016 election there are
a lot of people in this country that
were angry about the results but I for
my my charge and the charge of so many
of us in advocacy is what are we doing
with that anger and that's where like
indivisible was such an organic thing
that happened where you know you hear
the the cofounders of indivisible Lee
and Ezra who I work with a lot talked
about but there was everyone was like
how did we get here how did we get here
and it just the goal was to say stop
asking that question and like get
organized locally to do whatever bit of
change you want to do and I that has
been I think a really important goal for
advocates is to figure out how do you
channel people's anger to productive and
constructive action whatever that may
look like whether it's you know working
at the local level or or marching in the
streets in Washington so but apathy
is a really I find I'm very challenged
by apathy and my goal then is to make
people give a damn and in a lot of times
to me that's about telling stories about
human beings who are the people behind
these policies that are suffering you
know and then you know at a certain
point I'm like I'm I can't I can't get
through and we'll move on there's plenty
of other people but that's the thing
that I that I am the most challenge but
yeah I was gonna say the same thing
about anger and just I guess so on so
there's that so so for me so Vinita said
and I agree that anger is essential and
it can also be debilitating and though
for me the way to keep it but not be
debilitated is is by is by action so you
know like I can be like you know in
court sentences getting handed down
watching judges just be so callous to
people thinking about the structural
like unfairness the way that like nobody
in the whole city nobody in the system
cared anything about my client they did
nothing for her
no agencies activated mobilized no
resources deployed in in her whole life
when she was suffering and now at this
moment when she's committed a crime now
there's no number amount of resources
that we won't devote to locking her up
you know that is is is is angering and
it is infuriating and so for me the only
way that I overcome it is bye-bye
you know the civil rights attorney Brian
Siemens is always talking about
proximity and and and I think to me
that's exactly right I it's because when
I'm working with somebody one-on-one
when I'm talking to them then that is
actually I feel more moments of love and
grace and lightness and humanity then
and
that is a lot of what then keeps me
going because it's not the it's not just
the issue it's not an abstraction it's
this person and tomorrow I want to go to
court and I want to give her the one
thing that she never got before which
was somebody who cared to his toes and
was gonna fight with every inch of his
mind and heart to stand up for her and
demand that the system look at her as a
whole person in context and so that for
me is like is is then how I overcome the
anger that's how I keep the anger from
becoming unproductive and how you become
in proximity with people is going to
again be different depending on the kind
of work that you're drawn to right which
is what we're talking about earlier it
doesn't have to be an individual in that
one-on-one representation but I think it
helps when it is when it is a person I
think for for a lot of us it helps when
it's a person as opposed to an
abstraction and the thing that I'll just
say about apathy you know kind of
quickly and that isn't I feel like I saw
so many stories of my parents tonight
but but this I really like my dad used
to talk about this because my dad used
to talk about how how how ridiculous it
was the way the civil rights movement
was portrayed in media and in film like
we went to that we were watching this
film before he died and I we talked
about it afterwards and he said you know
I liked it but what I didn't like about
it was they made it seem like everybody
was in the movement and that is and and
and he's like that wasn't true
you know dr. Kim you used as you all
probably know you know dr. King was
deeply unpopular when he died the march
on Washington which is the only part of
black like black history that gets
presented in clips and in mainstream
media jury even the march on want the
march on Washington was unpopular when
it happened 60% of America
said in a Gallup poll that they think it
would hurt the cause of the Negro right
and you know 250,000 people were there
but then a decade later 10 million
people were like oh I was there and what
my dad was saying well my dad is saying
that I for me is so important is he said
look I'm not telling you this because I
want credit for being there first that's
not the point he said I'm telling you
this because I think that this history
is demoralizing and demobilizing to your
generation and to the next generation
because you call you have an issue you
call a meeting and six people show up
and five of them were at the last
meeting and you're like well what's
wrong with my issue because look at the
movement everybody was there millions of
people in the streets and so so what his
big point was is that you is it was that
is that as long as you are fighting the
injustice most people are not going to
care most people are apathetic most
people were apathetic in the civil
rights movement most people were not
marching most people were not doing
anything most people were going on about
their lives for good reasons or for bad
they were on the sidelines and that is
true in every movement for social change
and so for me it's a little bit helps me
kind of get to vanitas point where she
was like well I tried it now I'm moving
like that's the thing you got to move on
and like get your people but it's gonna
be a relatively small number of you that
are gonna create the social change that
you're envisioning and just know that
and don't be demoralized by the fact
that you've got so few people at your
meeting
can I just add cuz this is the grand
strategy program which sounds so grand
but I to put a finer point on that
there's it's also like know who your
audience is and what your who you're
trying to convince so I think Brian is
right on approximate being proximate to
the problem but most people in this
country are not going to meet the person
in addition they're not going to and so
or they're not going to you know know
the undocumented
child who was taken away from their
mother but the goal then is as an
advocate it's like for some folks it is
about this broader mass kind of
producing maths outrage and that's
communication skills and going that
route to figure out and for others it's
about trying to target particular
lawmakers or courts and/or media outlets
and but to me always the way even though
most people won't meet this person
that's where it's like whose story are
you telling you still need to break
through and the only way I mean all of
the criminal justice statistics showing
the gross racial disparities and the
number I mean we've all largely become
inured to that stuff because we're
hearing we grew up in it it's been
decades but it's the individual stories
we tell about the human beings behind
this stuff and you know I feel like so
much of the criminal justice reform
movement has been largely I mean now you
have governors whose sons have this
experience Jared Kushner whose father
had this experience nathan Deal in
Georgia whose son you know and we may
think well gee thanks for not caring for
30 years until but or you know you're
telling the story about the the five
year old kid who was torn away from
their parents and this person has a name
there's a photograph it's incredible how
much more effectually and that's a way
to build proximity across these divides
it is so much easier to have policies of
demonization and dehumanization when
it's just this like the words on a page
or the stats and I you know ultimately
sometimes you take it takes one story of
a human being to break through decades
of intransigence and I think that's all
part of strategy too it's about being
authentic and real and making sure that
you are protecting the person who's be
whose story is being told and that that
person has some agency and how they how
you're telling their story but that's a
really that's how you can we also have
to build that proximity to kind of break
that down since most people won't be be
for the reasons that you said James are
not going to go to their local jail or
prison to actually get to know somebody
I think we have time for one more
question maybe all the way in the back
there
I just had a question because I feel
like I guess as a young person who's
like aware of like aware about issues of
social justice reform um I think it's
like easy to look back and kind of be
like these people ended up on the right
side of history and like that was the
truth
but I find personally to be in this
space where like my truth is kind of
amorphous cuz I don't really know like
where it's going or what it's like gonna
end up being but I'm still very
dedicated to it and I still like hold on
to it very strongly but I also do have
this urge to kind of like change
people's minds and I understand that
their truths may be different so I was
thinking like in terms of the both of
you how do you kind of either get over
that urge to change people's mind or
accept that you can't change people's
minds because I find that to personally
be something like very discouraging and
if you can do it really quickly we might
have time for one more question I have
not gotten over the urge of trying to
change people's minds I just try to
change people's minds all the time
every day really I mean I was a totally
honest answer I I that's just what I do
and I mostly don't succeed but I just
keep trying yeah I agree I sometimes
worry that I'm in a bubble though that
I'm not enough around people who
disagree with me I used to be much more
in touch with people who were I mean I
still I'm still in working with
opposition and pretty serious opposition
but I think there's a different danger
which is that you only surround yourself
with like-minded people and you kind of
forget how to be sharp in these things
and have like the analytical tools but I
think we're always trying to change
people mine my thing though is you have
to know there was a lot of push after
the 2016 election to like court to move
away from voters of color and go like
start working on organizing the white
working-class and you know I was like
you can't pivot
you can't pivot away I'm not sure how
much of trumps base today I mean he was
real when he said 14 you know my base I
could shoot someone in the middle of
Times Square and they're so gonna be
living certainly seems that way for but
it
I mean you know so so that's a bit of
all of it I don't have the answer either
but I think it's important to engage all
right one one last question there are a
couple of hands maybe right in the
center here
all right wait you take both of them
since you're close by they want to
answer both so thanks to the both of you
for coming professor gage I think you
alluded to or I think I think you're
alluding to briefly to the first-step
Act that's going through the federal
government right now which is obviously
it's efficient in scope but I'm curious
to hear what the two of you think about
its substance and whether these sorts of
very centrist pragmatic bills are
productive or whether they sort of have
the effect that people on the right can
say all right well that's job done you
know we granted 2000 people clemency and
now we're moving on okay
so I did a lot of research on this
census for an internship last summer and
I was just wondering if you could talk a
little bit more about what's at stake
and what needs to be done to ensure a
fair count okay I so first step I just
quickly that Jamison could go into it a
little bit more so the Leadership
Conference opposed the first step act in
the house which was earlier in the
summer and we did it to the
consternation of a lot of our friends
and typical friends and allies on the
hill including folks like Van Jones who
is not on the hill but had a lot of
things to say about our opposition and
and we did it because we had been so
deeply involved in for years crafting
what was already a compromise around the
sentencing and Kirchner's Reform Act
circa and this pushed to have on bill
which in the house was completely back
in had a lot of problems around
recreating racial disparities through
the risk assessment instrument giving
Jeff sessions too much discretion around
release decisions or a lot of problems
around a whole host of technical things
and we felt like we needed to take a
really principled position and standing
back but we were in a very difficult
position as I said the Congressional
Black Caucus was supporting yet Hakeem
Jeffries was promoting at Van Jones and
and we were accused of well you know it
says bill helps one person you should be
for it and we were like do you know how
often Congress actually acts on criminal
justice reform like never it had been
since 2010 but like the last time that
Congress had passed a bill so we opposed
it we whip the vote against it we knew
that there were more folks in the house
that were going to vote for it but we
made a strategic calculation that we
couldn't and a principled one that we
were not going to stand for it and what
we were gonna do so at the time that we
were fighting Breck Cavanaugh's
nomination and chuck Grassley was the
face of that we were also talking to
chuck Grassley and saying you can't move
this bill in the Senate because it's
like a really crappy bill and it we can
do so much better and all of that work
that we had done around trying to put
front-end reform and sentencing reform
in it you have to stand strong on this
and what we did was then work really
seriously with the Senate with folks
like Mike Lee with chuck Grassley and
then of course with especially with
Senator Booker who was kind of our voice
in the Senate and Senator Durbin around
putting as much of what was in circa
into that bill making pushing for
retroactivity and we did it we pushed so
hard that we held our support for the
bill until 12 hours before the vote
because we wanted to hold the civil
rights communities and the Democratic
lawmakers feet to the fire look the bill
passed it is a significant bill I mean
there there are significant pieces of it
is it going to get us to the promised
land of ending mass incarceration no way
it is much less than the Circa bill was
which was already a compromise so we had
a lot of work to do when we have a
justice to parent that is willed
everything back around criminal justice
reform and is refueled the 1980s
policies and bill borrow 100% keep it
that way
when if and when he gets confirmed next
week and so that was the positioning and
some of the strategic choices we had to
make and now I talked so much and I need
to get to the census but no do do this n
do this
I'm the census so the reason why I think
it's like one of the most consequential
issues is you know every 10 years the
federal government it's written into the
Constitution it's the one government
program that is written into the
Constitution the government has to count
every single human being in our borders
regardless of status regardless of race
regardless of whatever and it is the
basis for political reapportionment in
the House of Representatives it is the
basis for the distribution of close to
eight hundred billion dollars of federal
money to every community in the country
for healthcare for education for
policing for every for every kind of
bread and butter issue that that relates
to our our lives and in 2021 just as it
was in 2011 it is also the basis for
state redistricting which governs how
state legislatures allocate power and
this is a hugely consequential thing
that happens in our country every ten
years it is supposed to be a nonpartisan
thing and as some of you may know very
quickly secretary Ross who's the
Secretary of the Commerce Department
still to this day somehow don't
understand why he is he decided to add a
question about citizenship status to the
census in March of last year he did it
using a ruse of asking the Justice
Department to send him a letter saying
that the Sessions Justice Department
needs citizenship status data to enforce
the Voting Rights Act I was responsible
for overseeing the Voting Rights Act for
two and a half years as were all of my
predecessors Ford and Democratic and
Republican administrations before since
the enactment of the Voting Rights Act
meant never has there been the
citizenship question on the short form
of the census this is the same Attorney
General who said that the Voting Rights
Act was intrusive so it was immediately
known to be a ruse there is litigation
around the country you can all imagine
the level of fear that exists around
reporting data to the federal government
we've all seen what is happening to the
dreamers and we're fighting like hell to
make sure that they can stay in the
country with legal status but there is a
lot of litigation this is a perfect
example of a situation
where it's gonna take litigation
although we there's some great great
Court decision but I don't have
confidence in the Supreme Court there's
a congressional strategy there's an
organizing strategy the leadership
conference has been really deeply
engaged but it is something that will
shape all of our lives for the next ten
years if we don't get this right and
it's why it's so important Steve Bannon
and Kris Kobach Lobby to have this
question added and there's nothing more
that they would like than a systematic
under account of communities of color
because it will radically affect
political and economic power of our
communities and so it's why I feel so
passionately about it I think that's a
good place to end Oh Oh soon as you
wanted you to have yeah yeah your guests
they can fine I'm in the law school I
have office hours
he's readily available he's just a Yale
professor yeah exactly
this has been either Gupta y'all well
please join me in thanking both
professor Foreman and Vanita Gupta for
this
[Applause]
[Music]